welcome to the thankful Thursday I
believe as entrepreneurs is important to
thank the people in your life who's had
an impact to help believe in you because
you can't do this alone and it's nice
just to every now and then reach out and
say thank you make them feel appreciated
so today i want to thank Brian Simon and
brian is a photographer friend of mine
here in Toronto int city he's helped me
with the number of different projects
who was a photographer at my wedding
he's got a pretty new business called
tarsi pic studios and I wanted to thank
him because Brian always goes way above
and beyond to make sure that his clients
are happy so I wanted to give a quick
example and this could be a lesson for
entrepreneurs as well so at my wedding I
wanted to give out wedding favors that
that weren't boring you know most
wedding favors are super boring it's a
it's a picture of the bride and groom in
a frame and and what am I supposed to do
without it's just to put that on my
mantel my supposed to hang on my wall am
I really gonna hang your wedding picture
on my wall right it's not going to
happen and so what I wanted to do is
make it more about the guests make it
about the people who are coming out and
give them something special that had
them on it so that they could actually
cherish that moment that they sent with
us that day I fought back to a photo
shoot that I did just on my own with
Nina I saw this picture of JFK and his
wife Jackie and I just liked how they
were sitting and I looked in you know we
got to do something similar let's let's
do something like that and i shot the
picture and I remembered that for the
wedding because I thought hey people
coming out to this wedding you know
they're all dressed up during their
suits and ties you're in there then
there are nice dresses how often you get
a professional photographer to take a
good picture of you when you're all
dressed up and looking nice not that
often so what I thought was here let's
take this JFK concept and take pictures
of everybody who was coming out to the
wedding so they could have that same
experience that we had so I told Brian
Brian I have this crazy idea okay i want
to make baseball cards with this pose
JFK couple shot on the front and
on the back I want to show candid shots
of that guests at the wedding at the
reception at the hall who are ever and
now this is having a lot of stress and
pressure on Brian because usually
photographer they come out they just
shoot the bride and groom a couple extra
shots and they're following them around
here he had to take pictures of
everybody you know that the set shot JFK
shot as well as all these other
candidate shots we can make an
individualized baseball card for
everybody so this is what it looks like
this is a buddy of mine John now I
haven't seen John for a while so I still
have to give him his card but this is
the the after result so this is him and
his girlfriend and then on the back is
not just pictures of us it's pictures of
him and his girlfriend that was kind of
before they came and then at the wedding
and then us all together and so it's a
nice memorable car that they can keep or
give them a little standard it can put
it up on their mental or desk whatever
and this is something that if I got this
from somebody I would actually keep this
like this is actually pretty cool it's a
nice memory from the wedding and that
was all thanks to Brian now Brian had to
take all these pictures then he had to
make the card right what pictures gonna
go on the front what's going to go on
the back then he had the source where
we're going to get the card from and
then aren't my related was putting them
in the cases so I didn't have that hard
a job but that was Brian right Brian
goes above and beyond he's never done
that he's never made baseball cards he's
never had to take pictures of everybody
out of wedding and he's like yeah let's
do it I'm on board he's excited because
he wants to WoW his customers from there
he's taking pictures of me at the beach
he's taking pictures of me for Christmas
cards he's done a lot of other stuff and
he's always gone over and over and over
beyond what I expected from him so Brian
thank you so much from the bottom of my
heart thank you so much for all the
great awesome work and for you watching
guys I'd like you to go and thank
somebody today's thanks somebody who has
had an impact on your business impact on
your life somehow it'll make them feel
great it'll make you feel great it'll
spread good karma out there in the world
and if you guys want to check out
Bryon's website you can check it out at
RC pic studios keep believing thank you
guys for watching I'll see you soon
if you want to see more great content to
keep you inspired motivated and
believing check out my newsletter in the
link below